As we start to better understand the coronavirus,
health experts are worried it could rival
the most devastating health
crises in recent decades.
Patients with coronavirus may have mild or
no symptoms and still be spreading it.
They have no fevers, no cough.
You could be unknowingly, unwittingly,
unintentionally spreading this.
To add to this it’s believed the coronavirus
is more contagious than seasonal flu.
Any method of disrupting the cycle of infection
is worthy of our attention.
Scientists in London who’ve had success
in detecting malaria have an unlikely method
they think could be used in preventing the
spread of COVID-19.
When you have an infection your body odor,
the smells coming from your body, change.
Which is detectable by mosquitoes.
So mosquitoes find you more attractive when
you have a malaria infection.
We wondered whether dogs could do the same.
The amazing thing about dogs is they've got
an incredible sense of smell,
they've got a very sensitive nose.
But they are also able to learn
and they can learn smells.
So by combining the two we were able to train dogs
to be able to detect the smell of malaria
very effectively above the World Health Organization
standards for malaria diagnostic.
So there is a very, very good chance that
COVID-19 also has a distinctive odor.
And if it does, then I am really
confident that the dogs
would be able to learn that
smell and detect it.
And how do you think it could revolutionize
our response to COVID-19,
having that kind of test available?
One of the main benefits of it would be that
we can rapidly find
people who have an infection
but don't have any symptoms.
So normally we screen people
for malaria when they present
with the symptoms of malaria
and find out if they have it.
What dogs would be able to do
with odors is find people
who are showing
no symptoms.
So those are the people who will
carry on a cycle of infection.
This is in it’s very early stages, do you
have a time frame?
So we're hoping that
within two to three months
we would have dogs
actually deployed and being
out there working to detect.
It's going to be really important that we
can monitor people
coming in and out of the country,
of any country really,
that is potentially infected.
So a screening process to allow
us to do that I think would be very useful,
This is really a form of screening
a large number of people.